early in the history of our solar system
something mysteriously knocked earth
slightly off its axis so today we tilt
at 23.5 degrees but what would happen if
we tilted even more what if earth spun
sideways on its axis well it wouldn't
take long before utter chaos ensued one
of the most important consequences of
Earth's axial tilt is the seasons
seasons happen because the tilt points
different parts of the planet toward the
Sun at different times of the year but
the tilt also means that different parts
of the globe received different amounts
of sunlight during each season and
that's where a more extreme tilt starts
to cause problems right now during the
summer in the northern hemisphere places
far north
like diavik Alaska received 24 hours of
sunlight for 82 days straight because
earth is tilted far enough on its axis
that as the planet rotates both diavik
never leaves direct sunlight on the
other hand the contiguous US receives a
max of 17 hours a day because after that
it rotates out of daytime sunlight and
in tonight but if we tilted Earth's axis
even more to 90 degrees the US would get
sunlight 24/7 around-the-clock for
months on end and it's not just the US
the entire northern hemisphere would be
like this at first animals would take
advantage of the extra light to find and
eat more food just like Alaskan birds
which feed their chicks extra nutrition
in the summer resulting in faster
growing babies than their southern
counterparts and plant growth would
explode since they get their energy
directly from sunlight farms in northern
Alaska for example grow cabbages the
size of Rottweilers in the summer but
while animals and plants would thrive
humans wouldn't
we evolved to be active during the day
and sleep at night but if we were
exposed to unending sunlight our brains
would stop producing the hormone
melatonin which we need to sleep at
night and that could lead to sleep
deprivation depression and ultimately a
more severe chronic version of these
symptoms called seasonal affective
disorder which already affects 9% of
Alaskans compared to just 6% of the
entire United States but that's less of
a worry than the floods temperatures at
the North Pole would more than double to
38 degrees Celsius from 15 point 5
degrees Celsius that's hotter than
temperatures at the equator today as a
result Greenland's ice cap would melt
causing sea levels to rise by seven
meters and flood nearly every coastal
city on earth say goodbye to New York
Copenhagen and Tokyo to make matters
worse the warmer seas would trigger
stronger and more frequent hurricanes
which form when seawater evaporates at
the surface and the weather wouldn't get
better when winter comes six months
later out of reach of the sun's direct
beams for months at a time the
hemisphere would get colder than any
winter on record swirls of frigid air
called a polar vortex which are normally
dissipated by warm air in the tropics
could travel all the way down to the
equator imagine blizzards in Florida
Brazil Kenya and all those thriving
plants they die from a lack of sunlight
agriculture would collapse as ecosystems
crumble and mass extinctions pile up and
there would be even more floods because
meanwhile the southern hemisphere is
getting toasty and the South Pole is
home to 90% of the world's ice the
constant sunlight would raise its
temperature to 38 degrees Celsius from
negative 28 degrees Celsius
melting the ice and raising sea levels
by a whopping 61 meters that's almost as
tall as the Leaning Tower of Pisa
Greenland's flood would look like a
puddle in comparison so all in all while
a few extra hours in the summer Sun
would be nice
let's leave the extra seasons to Alaska
and be glad the earth is tilted exactly
as it is